Ce matin je suis tombée par hasard sur mon horoscope.
Aujourd'hui les astres s'alignent.
Et une nouvelle page s'ouvre à vous.
Vos objectifs semblent plus que jamais atteignables et certains rêves vont se réaliser.
Mais Mars vous guette.
Alors attention de ne pas vous laissez engourdir par vos souvenirs.
Faut avouer qu'ils avaient plutôt tapé juste.
Qu'est ce que vous foutiez à cette soirée ?
Ashley on l'a vraiment pas tué hein.
Profitez-en, pour une fois qu'il ne dit pas de la merde.
Y a Ashley Collins.
Alban...
Tout le monde vous a vu avec la petite Ashley Collins aller vers le bassin.
Elle est jamais revenue.
Il entretenait quel rapport votre mari avec Ashley Collins ?
Pourquoi t'es parti à Los Angeles du jour au lendemain, hein ?
Y a un truc que t'as jamais pu supporter...
Laisse moi !
C'est qu'Ashley soit parti à Los Angeles sans toi !
C'est pour ça que tu l'as buté !
C'est pas sur elle que je me suis vengé.
Non, non ça c'est pas passé comme ça.
Tu te fous de notre gueule ?!
Ashley, je te présente mon nouveau mec, Tony.
Salut Tony.
Waow.
Et comme t'es une grosse pute et bah t'es allée jusqu'à me piquer mon mec !
Mais c'est pas moi ! Je vous dis que c'est pas moi !
J'avais tellement honte.
C'est que je suis pas du tout comme ces petites connes qui rêve de te ressembler.
Alors si t'as le malheur de t'approcher du père de mes enfants je te...
Je t'écoutes ?
Tu fais chier hein.
Yes !
Qu'est ce que vous avez fait à cette soirée avec Ashley ?
Qu'est ce que t'as fait ?
Bah je sais pas, c'est...
Pas de bol quoi.
Bah ouais mais...
En même temps c'est le jeu hein.